[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good one Rob hey everyone welcome to
Triforce it's meet Peter Brown I hope
you can hear me I'm gonna turn these
mics up because I can barely feel myself
what's up Rob okay what's up what's up
guys okay so we're gonna be Rob is gonna
be playing trials of the sword in master
mode today I am not even gonna bother
cuz I suck at this game at this point in
master mode it is so you're gonna carry
the team as you usually do let's be
honest ah I you know me in this game I
love it so much now a few weeks ago I
said that I you know I made this this
goal that we were gonna do this in
master mode yes Peter it is so hot I
like if people are familiar with Charles
of the sword you know where you fight
through a series of levels yeah with
nothing I can't get past for 10 floor
ten has three lizalfos I've I've done
this so many times to the point where
like I don't like this game anymore oh
[ __ ] well that's not true that's why I'm
here because maybe I will have that that
little insight that you were missing
yeah
probably not but I'm willing to believe
that together something magical happens
maybe you might even save Hyrule maybe
I'm not gonna save Hyrule
but maybe we'll save our pride maybe
we'll save something you didn't it II a
lot of food Peter hey
I think I'm a madman yeah I really do
because how do you have a job and what
the hell you're like running a
restaurant in this fight I know how to
make these really quickly and really
well these are required for this mode so
here's what you need to do when you kick
off master mode trial the sword is you
got to eat this stuff your body buff
your body with some stamina and this
okay are you ready I don't know what am
i I'm just sitting here man are you
ready
[Music]
so like here's the thing about this this
on master mode is that it's not a factor
of dying it's a factor of losing all of
your weapons so you get to set floor and
these guys are so overpowered yeah and
they have health regen yeah that like
you just run out of good weapons so
there are like straight-up crazy tactics
if you're in the chat Gani tips please
for the love of God give them to me
because whistle run is a tip that came
by but that doesn't necessarily help the
weapons issue that would only help you
avoid stamina to get away faster so a
lot of this is about getting the element
of surprise
yeah distracting enemies so they don't
pick like in this one it's all about
getting these bow Coughlin's away from
the the weapons here I normally had to
get this but I'm just so scared so Yugi
sir just interrupt real quick before
it's dvg on youtube suggest using the
bow to kill the first one and then doing
sneak strike for the others right but
does that work that well in master mode
right so that's the one tip I know it's
it's possible but like it's just like if
you screw up one little thing yeah
you're done and twenty to thirty minutes
is wasted you're done mister here we go
I know how many times have you played
through the first ten stages I don't
even I don't want to even say it Jesus
but that's great I love this game I'm so
happy that I can despite pissing you off
to no end still propel you forward to
keep going I think you guys to go this
is good this is good all right
thanks for joining us today guys just
reminder gamespot has twitch twitches
well we do twitch frequently but we also
have Swit switches streams every day of
the week Monday through Friday at 11:00
a.m. today is me and Rob tomorrow is
John Luke and Joe do you know what
they're playing
you can't talk right now you're busy as
hell maybe you're gonna play night trap
I don't know we'll find out I hate with
office so much that was dumb I'm already
night as well yeah to me Bruce Peters
make a bit yeah you bet we can
[Applause]
other things doing this on screen is so
top yeah
that's alright I won't talk to you much
white that reach crazy it has begun it's
okay we call that the training round
warm up stretch your bones yeah you know
that's the thing as I should have
stretched your bones ahead I should have
played ya I'm not using stasis my mind
is is flustered right now that's all
right that's a good call you're gonna
get there yeah light your stick on fire
let's good one how you doing I'm I'm
pretty good man there's been a hell of a
lot of games this past few days
observers a standout for sure I've been
playing Yakuza kiwami enjoying that
quite a bit still not totally sold on
the combat in that game but I swear to
god it's some of the best storytelling
damned in a video game it is by no means
a complicated or sophisticated story but
every single cutscene I am just like
glued to the TV like someone's gonna
betray who next who was gonna lose their
cool time what bad is gonna happen
so so yeah what's up Josh Shaw and
everyone else joining us in the chat
especially you goop's you riot
every time John Luke mentions game dump
my mind does not go to a good place
rob is focused even catch my poop joke
wrong weapon right in the butt
cool he didn't want that crap anyway oh
[Music]
man gube talking about watching softcore
porn in the aquazap is that in there is
anyone oh yeah and I went to a strip
club yesterday in the game and it
started off somewhat innocent it did not
it did not remain innocent for long ah
really yeah I mean the clothes stayed on
but you didn't need clothing to well I
mean you don't need to be naked to
understand what I mean yeah the
perspectives but it was funny to look
around at the other people in the strip
club and like how they were reacting was
totally oblivious to you so what was it
like excessive grinding or something it
was like I'm gonna so you're looking at
an upward angle right because you're
sitting in a chair and she's in a stage
and at first she's just kind of like
shimmy in side to side doing like sultry
walks but then she gets to the point
where you know like you know she's still
standing but legs spread knees bent
things just sort of twisting ever so Wow
to reveal that which is very adult I
took nothing wrong with that stuff it's
just like Yakuza is as its I always say
is that something sexist it is built for
men like a hundred percent like every
woman in the game is pretty much I mean
there's a couple women who do stand out
as strong characters but they never get
like the you know the the lion's share
of any scene or anything like that and
and then otherwise they get slapped
around and they they are treated like
sex objects it's just it's a jab it's a
Japanese video game about male gangsters
it's not surprising and I'm not here
grandstanding about it but it's just one
of those things mm-hmm I still really
enjoy playing it that I is a very
dramatic ridiculous ridiculous
experience there there was one scene
yesterday I forget how it started but
like this little girl you're protecting
she got grazed by a bullet and so you're
like kind of like taking care of her for
a minute and she's like recovered and I
was like idling standing next to her I
was just like kind of getting a beer or
something and she starts talking to the
main character about like oh I saw this
this toy store that had this weird thing
in the window and she I forgot what she
described and the main character kurios
like oh I think that that was probably
an adult toy store and she was like what
adult toy store but adult eyeballs don't
play with toys why would they need a
whole store he was like I mean I don't
tend to go I mean I don't but some
adults like to go it's like it was like
a third scene in the game talking about
sex shops and like there's this other
character you have in the sort of
partner of yours in the beginning of the
game who's trying to like turn you on -
just like embracing your kinks and going
to buy all the accessories you need wow
it's such it's such an experience bad
place yeah it really is
I acting pretty excited the stream there
you know what I almost want to do since
we've played yeah cos a zero and I'm
gonna beat this one is almost just pick
up on two o'clock is a to do the rest of
the series because I mean how do I put
this lightly like kiwami and zero are
you know modern like Reno they're sort
of like touchable zero is completely new
but kiwami he's like a touched up
version of the first game I kind of want
to see what the old stuff looks like
before it was filtered through what we
considered to be modern acceptable
open-world gameplay now
and especially because kiwami and zero
really do blend together a hell of a lot
like they are very much the same
experience just divided yeah I would say
Yakuza is a must play game if you if you
like gangster drama and you like
absurdist humor yeah absolutely
or if you ever nostalgic for Japan have
you been there or you want to know what
Tokyo might look like other than that
too much else
I love observer I can't wait to get back
to it
oh hell bleed [ __ ] finish it yeah I got
to finish hell blade and observer
Jacques oz is hanging over my head so
that review should be live next week I
also got fresh agents of mayhem no I
don't know you don't I
that game it at a very inconsistent
reception across the board which is
interesting yeah I know I did see
eurogamer's review I think it was
Eurogamer as reading in today that
seemed to align more with what you felt
and what I reviewer felt polygon had
similar Simon yeah yeah but like I felt
like most reviews I read they all found
something really positive to latch on to
and I didn't don't really know I mean
it's obviously different strokes for
different folks but yeah it's just some
of the games I guess I feel like if I
was an 11 year old and like my urns were
out of town and I went to a sleepover or
something like it would be like yep
uh-huh we're playing this all night yeah
yeah like that's the thing is is I
actually like would have a different
opinion of it I feel like if if there
wasn't swearing in it well I bet hey
that's that's what ruined Moira's
character and Resident Evil wrote
revolutions to the daughter of Barry
Burton if she tried to be this like
you know this every girl teenage punk
drama girl and everything was oh [ __ ]
balls like oh [ __ ] what did she say she
had she had like suck a [ __ ] I think she
said at one point yeah that's a new one
I love it it's like a [ __ ] mom
so lost a lot of hearts oh we're not
done yet are we
no sucka [ __ ] some Darney darker
according to the JC d1o get my memorable
expletives confused all the time yeah
now I understand this is going this is
going yeah I lost a lot of hearts so
it's not going well yeah but I'm still
kind of warm an option don't that
earlier I was just thinking about how
how did did you what do you who said
that you saw a guy do this one like
three hearts master mode or some like
crap like speedrun I don't know things
come and go out of my head so fast these
days sure that could've happened but I
don't remember it but I believe it I
believe it I don't know how people do it
but I believe it
Leonardo Enrique Bonin wants to know
who's gonna review Mario Plus rabbits on
game spots I have a hunch it's gonna be
me yeah yeah because once yeah Chris has
done I don't have another review on my
plate as of yet so do we I'm uh I'm
really bad at XCOM so I hope that it
crap the the influence is not going to
make it too difficult for me although
I've read a lot of previews that were
saying like yeah this game is really
tough don't underestimate it but also
those opinions were given after playing
like a section in the middle of the game
if you just had really good weapons this
would be much easier yeah there's a lot
of the tools I have that attack buff and
you got it like get through a lot of
this yeah yes you're damn horny you know
what I'm gonna talk about sleepovers
how come adults don't have sleepovers
for real because that's just called
getting drunk at your friend's house and
passing out on her couch yeah okay whoa
I mean it's not like I'm not saying like
you know get sleeping bags and everyone
like sleep on the floor watching like
bad horror movies but you know what I
mean yeah I guess we're all tired is
that it no sort of sleep in her own bed
go to the bathroom in our own bathroom
in the morning yeah life's short have a
sleepover while you can where it's like
everyone's scared in life or adult life
- like - like that was dumb oh you're
doing it to like show all your like
weird habits okay yes I don't have such
as well I'm taking boogers and putting
them on the walls oh do you know those
are gone no do you know that they're
back what are you talking about there
there's one little one left but most of
them have been stripped away yeah but
someone went to the effort to like
remove them and now they're back I was
look this morning I saw one damn
there's no this I'm saying there's one
but like when you explain what we're
talking about so what we're talking
about is someone in the men's bathroom
on GameSpot's floor of our CBS
Interactive office next to the shorter
urinal that presumably is designed for
shorter people kids they've been please
that's a good point they've been they've
been putting boogers on the wall wiping
them on the wall well wiping them yes
yeah it's sort of organizing them in a
scattershot fashion and I noticed this
the first time a couple months ago and I
mentioned it to someone and they didn't
really seem that interested in it but I
got drunk at work after hours yeah about
a month ago
and I just kind of said that's enough I
got a I gotta tell everyone and everyone
is well aware of the fact that they're
boogers all over one of the walls her
bathrooms now and we're talking like a
dozen at least and intentional it
definitely intentional just in that one
spot about a week ago I noticed that
someone had not done a thorough job but
had gone to the effort to say wipe them
off or knock them off the wall or
something there's one above the urinal
which remains and then the rest of them
you can sort of see like what remains of
their corpses maybe that's what I'm
looking at bits and pieces on the wall
yeah it's a little it's like little tiny
fragments that are left that I saw I'm
gonna I'm gonna shout this out for you
because it's confusing to me but I like
it
operator badger of team porn kills love
says I went to my friend gameís rental
yesterday check out his channel he's a
good guy just he's a conspiracy theorist
okay so if you're in for a good guy
who's got some conspiracies check out
that channel I guess don't so hi we got
to hear about the gross stuff in life
it's just kind of you know everybody
poops but back to back to sleepovers do
you want do you want me to come over to
your house and have sleepovers ever you
asking no I'm not I didn't invite you
into my house you're damn no but well
look I got a tiny apartment right I mean
what are we gonna do you're gonna hear
every noise but you've got you got a
sizable space I could tell your reason
actually not thing about it is that most
people our age have roommates and those
roommates have different friends for
instance my roommate had his cousins
come over sleepover yes super houses for
the outside Lance yeah three people I
didn't really enjoy it because there
goes my living room we have one bathroom
there goes my bathroom time Wow yeah
that's true
so we had it yeah but it's your turn for
bathroom time who knows what you're
walking into
right Peter this is going okay I did
okay that round you know what I think is
helping is this secondary conversation
we've got going on have you ever found
that like when you're doing something
and you are like talking about something
else you like realize like wait I've
been subconsciously performing well the
entire time yeah I'm like that with
Street Fighter no I'm not making that up
yeah sometimes rocket League maybe sure
yeah all right lose all those lose all
those you're not even there yet and
you're already thinking about it they
scare me I had I have I can have
nightmares of those guys they're so fast
that marciella know whoa Matt Marcille
has a four-bedroom house and his wife's
friends occupy the extra rooms all caps
constantly I don't know if that's a bad
problem to have that would depend on
your oh you're a big fella
console hot I don't know if that's a
program Eric Green said if I lived in SF
I would invite Rob over to a non-sexual
sleepover hey you know why not make it
sexual yeah I mean look I'm not
necessarily saying that I want to have a
lot of sleepovers but you know
sleepovers am i right go over there you
big dumb idiot
another thing missing from childhood
that I wish adults participated in was
goodie bags at birthday parties remember
I don't know if you had those oh good
old goody bag go to birthday party and
you'd leave and it usually be like a
brown paper bag like the mom would write
like in creative letters like your name
something or just be a standard bag but
you'd go home with like candy a little
trinkets and [ __ ] let them know that hey
thanks for coming I know this day has
been all about little Rob over here but
we appreciate you too I'm saying
what do you think goodie bags are called
in the UK scrumptious sacks sweet sacks
this this four went horribly wrong did
you start to imagine the sort of goodie
bag you would get as an adult
yeah how did that not affect you dude
that was a real good threat wasn't it
regular Wade Boggs over here get out of
here I had to choose goody bag
ingredients start with the obvious good
a can of beer some of the shady I don't
care depending on what state I'm in
maybe enjoy
let's see some sort of video game themed
magnet put on my fridge one of those
little poppers the things you you know
you pull the string goes boom it like
stuff flies out maybe a small thing of
artisanal cheese crackers perhaps bag of
Doritos thank you
Corder heart should I restart look so
look at look what this stuff does oh
good this is half a heart hylians room
does oh look at all these but oh look at
the computer look at all these years a
total of four hearts waiting in your
inventory just do it
[Music]
I'll tell you what Rob I promise the
next time I have a birthday party
it'll be goody bags I turned 30 and
October you're not 30 yet
I hope Blue Angels line up on my
birthday the frickin Blue Angels fly
over San Francisco
at least once a year maybe twice and it
is the most jarring event ever like the
office shakes yeah the best story I have
is uh I believe when Willie Brown was
mayor it's Fleet Week is basically the
event right and the Blue Angels were
like we're gonna can we do a flyby
Thursday like around like 2 p.m. to do
our practice run they always do like a
practice run and what I was like
absolutely not you will not flyer near
the city at all you do better not and
they go okay Thursday 9:00 a.m.
frontpage of like The Chronicle was like
the formation right Air Force defies
mayor I can't think of the building was
the Poynting building Miss America right
oh the Bank of America big America is
the big one trans trans America right
sure I don't know you grew up here
did I feel like I grew up here no way
but like as an adult I came to the city
19 with two bags and no friends I was a
very different person I used to wear
Birkenstocks I actually still think
Birkenstocks very comfortable I'm not
disparaging Birkenstocks
yeah I got that don't and you know what
okay here wat them while we're talking
with random [ __ ] Birkenstocks with socks
what is with people against all that I'm
alright
is it a crime to look sorry to feel
comfortable and look like you're just a
casual mountain man at the same time
nothing so nice pair of wool socks and
some brown leather Birkenstocks maybe
you got yourself an afternoon comfy
afternoon oh I almost want to do
something else in this game this is real
real hard but this is like hmm this is
something we're like if I were to
complete all three of these on master
mode it's a milestone in my life [ __ ]
and I would be I get to witness it too
if you do it if I'm here when you do it
today so what is it what mistakes are
you making I would say that I am a lot
of this is isolating and picking one guy
but it's difficult when there's three
swarming you so my might my instinct is
to like run away and drop bombs are you
getting like ahead of yourself here are
you feeling like maybe maybe to like
overconfident and he's like minor
scenarios like do you just need to slow
it down or right or what I should I
think I should it's good call thank you
come here that I'm seeing a lot of
positive support for Birkenstocks in the
chat I like this so thank you
looking at Philo digging again and now
people are talking about b-movie did you
ever see that crap b-movie whoa what's
the deal with ash I don't know if that
movie's bad or not I haven't seen it I
shouldn't say
I want to walk it out no no God doesn't
say like more videos unlike the best
practices because I there's a I really
just was watching for the one the 410
with the lizalfos yeah those decent be
proud of who you are and what you've
done
we're viola here thing that was good
Christopher Walken there's more Ravalli
in the oh it's gotta be the champions
ballad I hope what I hope is that
Nintendo has been watching and they're
going to adopt our facet of his
personality just knowing it he was
watching his like cinematics the other
day he's such a pretentious oh I guess
you saw my sweet aerial moves huh well
you can't have this console hots talking
about seeing Linc
growing up with a beard which reminds
like you what do you look like I don't
think so maybe I'm very soft and out of
shape
very soft we've got a game called
Chronos which doesn't it's not quite
Zelda it's not quite Dark Souls it's not
quite resident evil but it kind of has
things from all those series combines
but one of the really interesting
mechanics is every time you die you aged
a little bit before you're revived and
so you get to watch your character grow
from this sort of like young
20-something hero into an older man and
as they get older they also lose their
physical abilities but they gain
super interesting system and you know
that makes the death not necessarily
necessary but not as punishing as you
might think
actually yeah everyone knows reminds me
of my dog when the doorbell rings like
oh my god it's not the worst they just
like have to continue like another
minute he has got someone took the
limiter off of his larynx he like opens
up his diaphragm just so to get the
loudest bark out possible it is ruff is
real real rough the other weird one is
when like people like I don't know I
can't remember if I don't people like
get their dogs like bark fixed or
something like that or like removed I
think in my thinking of that right and
it's like what they make is like just
like oh my god this is so sad are you
[ __ ] with I I may be something the
check and confirm yeah
Wow his horrible stink
I mean people put bark collars on dogs
I've never heard of them like yeah can
you cut my dog open and like change its
bark I'm not having this if there's one
thing that like is gonna be the end time
a humanity when like aliens show up
they're like you what you were doing
this look we're down with adult
sleepovers and goodie bags but taking
bark away from a dog oh this is it this
is around it so get down it's the little
things that was a tactic recalling that
was the tenth tactic with the speedrun
right we're like he was doing the wind
up and getting like a double hit on each
Oh on each pass these do people are
actually just confirming your thing I
can't believe it
I know it's not just unbelief as awful
it's like crazy
I mean hey eye-for-an-eye right so did
we do that dog you better do that owner
that that should be the contract the vet
should be like look we will do this but
just know that you have to have the same
thing done to you
Yeah right I still actually wouldn't
really condone it but I would feel not
as it sucks either way if I get the vet
should be like I'm just kidding I'm not
doing it to your dog I'm just gonna do
it to you you [ __ ] it's like that's
taking kind of the easy way right yeah
why don't you why don't you just like
talk to your dog you got to get out
there and train your [ __ ] dog you got
a responsibility with that it rendered
out louis c.k bit i think this was
referring to her he's like you think I
get why people hit their kids but he was
like what'd he say he said um that's not
taking the easy way out isn't it like
you tried talking to him like that's all
he does is play video games I don't why
you gave him a video game Dave my sister
and her brother and her brother Wow
my sister and my brother-in-law her
husband their kid man they've they've
figured out how to be Stern but flexible
parents like in a ways I've I've never
seen before I go there and I am freaking
shocked at how like sternly Arthur kids
but like only in terms of like hey we
agreed on some rules right you gotta
follow those rules and the kids are like
no you're right if we did
phylla dig'em I don't think that's what
I'm saying meaning that if you neuter a
dog to get castrated because as Bob
Barker let us know the pet population is
a real problem what's with everyone like
doing like the spacing I don't know I
think it takes a lot of time it takes
quite a bit of time I get a review from
a real answer once that had two spaces
between every word and I exclaimed
confusion and dismay but I was told by
people on the team that no that is
actually a style for some some schools
or some outlets I don't know maybe they
don't print it that way but that's how
they asked for it we submitted weird to
make I think they called it the French
space man if I beat this I swear to God
be the happiest little boy I hope you
beat it man you deserve to be happy
Thanks
I love his shorts jorts he's so stylish
he kind of is he's got some ugly
equipment right like that phantom armor
come on
I want something necessarily his is it
you choose to wear it battles design the
clothes they wear please damn I feel
like the noise the book columns are
making it's probably that this spark
organ removed sounds like yeah yeah get
your ass down here
alright so file John was saying I was
trained double-spaced for periods
semicolons and colons I find that
handsome clarity ease paragraph reads
fair enough
crap
the animations of the enemies are so
cool so pissed
no it's really fun to do is freeze
freeze bow Cobb ones on horseback or you
freeze and they're just and that the
horse keeps going oh really they Adams
gonna Jody look at cool so dumb it's
I'm not doing too bad no you're doing
great
how'd you ever end up finishing pyre no
dude that's another one that's it's
longer than the other two I don't blame
you follow time I pronounced that
correct but somehow I did that properly
[Music]
arrest in that area out hit me where it
hurts
trying to bort that I show you that
showed you that the other day it's
really cool trick so you don't like dant
you don't damage the weapon oh my god
character for like another thing he's
like maybe I shouldn't be washing so far
away
kids these days in the double spaces
damn Millennials are killing grammar
punctuation I don't know we had lunch
spaced for a whole article hi to type a
thousand words before I was allowed to
use a space and the nurse and the noddle
to rap my knuckles with an iron rod wake
up blisters everywhere
[Music]
grandpa's Thanksgiving please Oh huge
Lego set we'd have the $5 one and we
were happy man I really can't wait till
I'm old man I remember when I got my n64
for Christmas yeah just Nick you're high
you're a high little kid just like
screaming remember like there's like
there's that real famous warhead oh boy
she just kind of wants to join in on the
excitement like mine what's the best
Christmas present I ever got
oh I never okay there was one I don't
know why I'm thinking about this there
was one birthday there's maybe like
seven or eight years old
and I had just seen like one of the
Batman movies I think was the first one
probably yeah so I was probably [ __ ] now
I must been younger like five or six and
so my birthday kind of came and went but
my grandparents who live a little bit
far away came the next weekend to hang
out and it brought me two presents and
then just returned from a trip to Mexico
so the first thing I got was like a
varsity jacket you know like a leather
jacket but with a B it was like black
and yellow for like Batman and I was
although the other gift they bought me
was a adult sized sombrero so basically
they got me the coolest outfit possible
for a little boy it was a great photo of
me wearing both like forcing a smile
like thank you I remember when I was
young I got the what was what was the
the when the Power Rangers assembled in
their beasts and they assembled into
what what was it
Oh Megazord Megazord I got bat
as a toy that's pretty rad oh man but
the thing was oh crap the thing was in
the right home I have an older sister
younger brother younger sister just you
know stoked that I got this dude wow
these guys were so dumb
my sister was like well can we play with
it and my mom was like yeah of course I
want to play with it oh my god this is
the worst that's why I buried a couple
of them in the long my brother buried on
a camping trip in Maine if anyone wants
to go to all of Maine and look for these
his original Star Wars toys like he's
like simulating something like maybe
like a mass grave I don't know
you know who's he I think maybe he found
that's perfect
appropriately enough he found like bid I
forget his name but you know at the
trashcan won the Droid oh the kong-kong
yeah yeah are those toys even worth
anything now anymore
I know there was like height like a
decade ago yeah well Eric gave me a
whole bunch because he thought they were
going to be worth something
no they're not the new ones are not or
the contemporary you know thanks get
robbed how many stages deep are you into
this three I normally can do these req
these guys pretty easily but not today
show that turd who's boss you did oh god
hello Minnie are there it's fine don't
worry about it do you think wasting time
knock his block off
oh look he hates it freeze
in the name of the love you know what
these you know these sound like C Mon
oh my god it's known as such a book
gobbling Josh please be watching still
oh my can carry that message forth unto
Mary's mind Sasha Bo cobble and that dog
[Laughter]
get up if Bo goblins would [ __ ] apart
it smells like he's farting right here
boy that dog I swear to god his farts
could power a small nation for like a
month you his farts and I'm being dead
serious his smart smells so bad that you
feel them you feel it before you smell
it hey thanks for how long is what thing
going on I don't know what you mean
freezing your dog ah
the King of Hearts
[Music]
one of the same if you took if you stay
fetid dog farts it's farting if you
removed Simone skin you would see a puff
of far and it would dissipate get up
robbed someone in the chat is saying we
can never pay again for live sex if we
click this one link Wow
can you save that key copy and paste
I've been paying for live sex for a long
time and I'm tired of it I'm sick and
tired of paying for my live sex I've got
you sure that'll work what's really you
think Mary's got like a chat monitor and
twitch anytime someone system oh and she
like gets logged into the chat oh man
[Music]
this is Mary it is a what would you call
it a postmodern evaluation of a dog
perhaps greater than us all and the
universe combined that which we fail to
understand but that we interpret due to
our own means and you know our own
understanding of how the universe
operates or we're just talking to show
you about your dog sorry
right around oh dang it you blew it take
a knee oh-oh-oh-oh feel like mary is
preparing like a real scathing chat
commenting it's taking her so long for
bed all right I don't know it's time
that me and Mary hung out together hung
out a while
agreed that's fine I don't think there's
anything in these guys yeah that's fine
Josh I didn't mean it anyway now we get
to take a little bit of a breather
oh and collect some goodies yeah hang
out Josh but don't bring Mary but bring
Simone so we can talk about Simone gosh
I still have to go over your apartment I
haven't seen your cats have you met his
cats yet I don't think so dude
hiding his cats it's cats are too cute
for us
Stephanie right now is obsessed with the
idea of getting a second cat which would
be two cats and one dog in a one-bedroom
apartment just make it as Lou oh man I
really hope we do this the sleepover
Josh mentioned yeah me too
sure that means I get to beat this
master mode without looking at the clock
how long you think you've been playing
for an hour
close enough not quite well don't keep
you in suspense how long 52 minutes
dummy silly kitty
if anyone the chat can help what what's
the best way to do it this way to use
eggs in this game scram oh I've been
eating it an ordinate amount of eggs
lately because I'm a diabetic and I find
it hard to find foods that are both
satisfying to eat and leave me feeling
full omelettes sorry but I don't I don't
know if I have the right ingredients
already I don't have butter I would need
butter I think yeah that's true oh I got
one banana Oh
my kingdom for a second banana
marty'll says I have a cat a Great Dane
and a bunny it sucks a Great Dane that's
like two dogs combined that is a lot of
animal yeah I've heard that things with
fish
I've heard that bunnies are smellier
than most people assume bunnies Oh or
like ferrets right yeah I so I feel like
you could probably connect to a ferret
pretty easily because they've got
expressive ish faces I'm sorry thing to
a bunny I don't know maybe just haven't
spent enough time with bunnies damn goob
telling like it is ferrets Melies
bunnies suck maybe that was a good
that was a good combo um did that again
Mary you missed the the thing where I
invited you to hang out with me and Josh
told me you didn't want to so I just
made plans with him instead it was great
you should have been there Eric Green
says it's cuz they walk around in their
own urine and I don't know if that's
whoa the rabbits of the ferrets seem a
little hostile Great Danes are dog
Megazords nice was Jamie's on YouTube
thank you for that Mary if I'm not
talking about farting I'm thinking about
farting be at my own or someone else
in my region area hipsters with Jaguars
Tigers this is Rio Duloc mid-con that's
impressive and hard to believe thank you
talking yourself kind of both three so
on three floors from now is is the one
that doesn't is the floor that doesn't
help me sleep at night doesn't it make
sense doesn't whatever oh great yeah
personals office yet they still like
pretend they're closed
Robbie getting chastise for cooking or
not cooking enough man I think you got a
raven I think you gotta check out Rob's
stat side of Master mode because it is
replete with fascinating dishes such as
this is the other problem is that
inventory here is that you when you like
attack them they'll go in the water and
regain health
Mary are you going to TGS by chance this
year the Tokyo Game Show oh my god
God Peter oh my god did he just use that
leaf to throw a bomb back at you
oh is that what happened is what
happened no that was but that was
accidental he had already engaged the
wind and I was dumb and reacted wowza
that was clever [ __ ] or whatever it was
I don't know but that was something goob
the dates for TGS are September 21st in
the 22nd for business days and 23rd and
24th for the public and I believe I'm
cleared to return for my first time and
haven't been in the last two years off a
walk I've been in Japan yes
I keep doing anymore yes Mary I looks as
though I'm going to let them go Mary I
do remember the food triangles and it's
a good chance that Ed is going as well
so you know we could make the human food
triangle as it were
the food triangles Mary's referring to
are essentially like compact triangle
bricks
of rice that are wrapped in seaweed
maybe sometimes they have the pork in
the middle listen
dried squid and maybe even just
mayonnaise a few good things josh TGS is
at the end of demo
come over here Josh I legitimately want
you to hide one thing in Tokyo and give
me like a small series of clues may give
me a scavenger hunt
oh god Macari yeah Gamescom is a
nightmare an absolute nightmare in
Germany cologne specifically at that
time of year hot humid deodorant is not
a thing that everyone wears it stinks
and you gonna give some robbed you go
last year non-event man it's one of
those shows where i i i never wanted to
return after like my second trip but I'm
just you know I'm a soft hipster from
San Francisco and so apparently that
leaf is pretty critical for you to have
according to Josh why you know I don't
think that the leaf has durability so it
can help you build distance or like at
least control what you can over a
scenario oh you mean just then Josh okay
I got you
yeah I know I saw that too and it was a
little unfortunate but yeah if you don't
need it for the rest of it then don't
worry about it just for that moment
I think we're crossing hairs crossing
streams
I'm sure Siena wants to know have you
ever been to England me yeah yeah yeah
when I was with my family I could what
when I was a kid there you finally found
out my secret I have a kid okay
[Music]
okay
what's in you box come on oh my god
tight you're doing good kid
the whole town believes in you I've got
your back all 156 of us get up Josh
don't bury something in a park or bury
something in the park I don't care
I was hoping more like something you
could like tuck into like a nook of a
building in the middle of the city
whoops
right now Justin wants to bury the thing
Josh is hiding with booth
drop your wand just take a breather yeah
nope okay Josh claims that if the thing
he hides is merely poop and that it's
not covering another thing in poop that
will save him time and money my question
to you good sir is where is this poop
that you are supposedly hiding coming
from and assuming that it's your own
food you really want to handle your own
poop like that sorry this discussions
[Music]
yeah okay what if you just hated like a
photo of Simone somewhere I just said
part
great Oh pickle Rick this next one I
think I'm scared Peter I have all the
confidence in the world that you're
gonna do this
are you ready I'm ready
Steve someone earlier mentioned that
maybe I should actually I'll shut up
shut the hell up
what is this fascinating trick you're
doing my heart is racing it's probably
cuz it's like a thousand degrees in this
room right
[Music]
[ __ ] that was really [ __ ] unfair my
god cool friend what are you cool friend
yeah I'm not doing that again though I
don't think no that's crazy
but you did really good frankly god man
should we have Nick do it now just to
watch him fail get really pissed off I
mean I don't know I don't do this I
think we might have to call it should we
just call it unless there's one thing
you want to do outside of this in the
game before we go six snowboarding if
there is some six snowboarding to be
done
you know it's a bummer is I had that
ferry and that ferry would have saved me
it doesn't trigger automatically no I
used it I didn't mean to I mean I got my
ass kicked on a dumb area [ __ ]
should I do one more it's got to take
another hour I needed I need at least it
takes an hour turn the fan up get some
water
yeah I guess I could have I was saying
that that like putting more more into my
hearts as far as like opposed stamina
[Music]
yeah because you don't yeah you don't
really run out of stamina do you but
you're already going to the maximum that
would only help you preserve a few it's
up to you man if you want to do it I
just need to get some water because I
literally am very hot in this room but
then I'll be right back now so pour that
water he's doing it
do my heart was beating I believe it
actually this may not take a whole hour
because you all go faster go faster a
lot of it too was getting familiar with
those layer ones yeah sorry I'm sorry
Peter what I'm just sorry sorry I didn't
do it right
I'm so sorry the only thing I'm upset
about is I've run out of interesting non
sequiturs to bring up Jen oh you're very
concerned about let's see are you gonna
get an SNES classic do you care about
that thing I'd love to but I just know I
won't ever get whoa how'd that guy get
there like oh my god reach that dumb
sorry I can't go I can't start like that
dude yeah I would love an NES classic
but SNES yeah yes sorry yeah and did you
hear it like in like New York people
like buying them and then going down the
line of people waiting to get them and
saying like give me double like flipping
it in line like that's just so messed up
yeah like taking advantage of the
situation you know like it is taking
advantage of situation I think the
capitalists in me would say well they
they got there early enough they were
the one who had to spend more time
waiting in line yeah but still I imagine
those people are doing so just to sell
it to turn a profit mm-hmm which is
their right to do but you know what gain
any most excited I think for me would be
stupid Mario world having easily
accessible I mean I already have these
games in there Final Fantasy 3d and
Super Metroid are two really incredible
games and to have those just to be able
on the fly and a very easily portable
device which is great
because they sure as hell aren't on
switch let's see other than that
earthbound yeah we good to have that
starfox to having played some of the
prototypes that have been floating
around online it's not that amazing so I
don't really know I think we're gonna
review that I've said with certainty
that we will review it but I have to
wait and see what it's like really what
our schedules like at the time I really
want to get my hands on one of the
European ones cuz they're super nintendo
looks like the Japanese Super Famicom
and we'll have all the games that we
have in English but with that system
that is just more aesthetically pleasing
it is already went up to pre-order like
in the UK I think like a month or month
ago or something like that and so that
[Applause]
not do that move Jamila Gonzalez the
third welcome back what did you miss
well Rob got to the lizalfos and the
risottos got to ride cause that was the
easily the most progress I've ever had
like I actually killed one of them
you killed two of them I thought no just
well the first one is doesn't count
yeah he's as weak but it's that those
two other
[Applause]
[Applause]
we should have stopped it
you should have stopped I'm sorry we
should have maybe not gone further but
well see what you can do then I'll try
goes fast like what well he's gonna keep
says it'll get me on a bee
let me need i pre-ordered two from
Walmart when they put them up just so I
could yes it's not one to somebody else
nearby for like retail but then Walmart
cancel all those pre-orders I'm assuming
they only canceled them because they
they didn't know how much they'd altum
Utley get from Nintendo and thus being
like sorry the first thousand people get
to keep their pre-orders that would be
something they would have to address
immediately and they didn't really know
what to say I'm assuming all right we're
cancelling the ball whoa dude
hey Joss said it said it earlier the
fire what oh no don't
I can't let that burn don't burn I BRE
actually Saiga is never going to give us
a Dreamcast maybe never I'm still
waiting for them to get out of their
contract or at games that country that
makes the really crappy Genesis consoles
they've apparently fixed some of the
problems with the Genesis they reviewed
a few weeks back I told people not to
buy I still think that you should not
support that company's business
practices because their packaging is
incredibly misleading for a product that
says Sega Genesis flashback console 85
games and only 45 of those are actually
Genesis games I don't care how that
compares to the amount on the Super
Nintendo class really being as classic
they're lying to customers who don't
know better and that is [ __ ]
that's my random I'm sorry and the CEO
even offered to have an interview with
us which I'm inclined to take because I
feel like they're either oblivious to
how poorly receive their products are or
they're trying to be Shady I'm gonna
give them the benefit of the doubt and
say they're a small company and they
don't quite get their position in an era
where the NES classic is so popular and
in demand but that Senate that Sega
Genesis flashback contract is
[Music]
one arrow one shot
[Applause]
Oh Oh what do I hate more than companies
lying about their products surprise
olives and dishes that didn't have olive
in the ingredients list disgusting
[Music]
people love olives and I died I won't
say they're wrong but I just oh I did I
love I especially love olives on pizza
man mmm olive just olives so I want my
pizza hmm I have to say you with that I
could just taste them while you kept
saying olives olives olives olives it
was just all I could taste I like Marc
martini olives - oh that's oh man I had
this friend
Heather's wrestle oh oh I had this
friend once who was like talking about
it's got this nice martini shaker
whatever and I was like that's cool I
don't really like olives and he's like I
make a really good martini I was like
that's fine I hate olives Peter you're
not hearing me right so he comes over my
house after telling me all this and he's
like all right so I brought the thing
I'm gonna make them you want one and I
was like I don't he's like come on come
on I make really good ones I was like I
don't want one
he's like I won't put one on the
toothpick or ever I was like that's not
gonna make a difference but fine god I
hate that persistence don't do that and
so he made it for me I took one step and
I was like this is I'm sorry dude like I
can't drink this and he got pissed at me
for wasting the the drink he made he's
like that'd be 20 bucks
whoa sorry
oh yeah you gonna love it Bijou speech
Oh goob everyone is a reviewer I'm
nobody special god damn you justin's
oliver view of 12 out of 10 is
definitely a paid review I had someone I
had someone yesterday get upset at a
freelancer for a review of the long dark
two different people claimed that
because it wasn't paid for the review
I'm the long dark I actually I'm not
familiar with that game it's a survival
game it's been really yeah it's it's a
fine game that is hamstrung by story
that's not that great apparently and
some quirks some technical and design
quirks that sort of hampered the
survival mode according our reviewer I
mean a six out of ten is is close to a
positive score without you know being
super negative and man I'm just I don't
know people III thought that whole thing
about paid reviews ended I thought
people stopped talking about that
because it never happened at GameSpot
ever ever
and especially and especially the chance
of our freelancers who work their asses
off usually as a second job to review
video games because they love video
games and want to share their opinions
on the gall to claim that the hair
somehow part of the collusive system
that doesn't exist
excuse me a real wedgie means that
that's uncomfortable huh
the Cana lives to thing was not a paper
review that was a dispute over then
management of GameSpot and essentially
how we treat reviews of games when
they're advertising on site it was
hailed in a [ __ ] way and it was
addressed when we bought giant bomb so
that controversy is also still brought
up today and it's maddening because it
was almost a decade ago damn under way
different management in a way different
system
oh he's gonna do that dumbass oh my god
I got to isolate these best Eric green I
have no idea of collusive is a word or
not didn't stop me from you ever tried
to get into the minds of someone who's
like a youtuber like you know okay how
do they handle streaming any bigger cuz
they always have high energy right they
always have I've noticed the trend is to
describe every single thing happening on
screen so there's never a moment of
silence right that takes energy whether
or not it's a valuable approach to game
coverage for you I don't know boys ship
is that take a lot of energy I can't
even stay on a single train of fire
right now most thing is I'm talking to
myself yeah okay I just I'm getting real
angry now which I think it has been a
there's been a a good use my energy how
much I hate these guys so much
oh yeah no no oh no Peter Peter pumpkin
eater yeah
so maybe it does it doesn't regen all
the way their health look like I just
has stopped I guess that is a fish how
are you man
whoops
sorry I clicked the wrong thing where
are we Rob where did we go where are we
I clicked gamma3 nothing there that's
weird
Oh God well we'll have to cover that
with teh talk about that wow dude you
put on a good show dude and what can I
say you did your best you learned some
lessons we've we figured out why adults
and kids are different we maybe we've
you know planted a seed for goodie bags
to make a resurgence and hey why not
sleepovers too
also it's it's perfect it's it's a
perfect time to leave because it was a
good way to go out uh-huh
it's 12:30 I got to eat some food thank
you guys thank you guys a lot this has
been fun who knows how much longer we'll
play Zelda but expect perhaps Yakuza
hijinks yeah dude absolutely yeah
1%
that's a guarantee all right thank you
for watching everyone it's been fun
chatting with you have a wonderful
Thursday a great Friday and an even
better weekend until next week
take care